okay so that's stinky but um well done
you've done a really hard part of this
can we have a look at part two
you have a look at party show hands who
had anything on the page
for part two just anything at all didn't
get there
you got something anyone else
okay but it's something okay i'll still
write that that's okay
let's have a quick look at the question
what it's asking it says
explain this is the other reason why
this question was so hard
in the hsc mathematics paper like you
guys know the hc keywords right
the hcc keywords they appear like
describe compare and contrast
discuss right exactly right so we've got
a whole bunch of them we
hardly ever use the word explain
right right okay so that people are
already in sort of the wrong frame of
mind
explain why all the solutions of four
cos x equals two minus x
pause before you even go to the rest of
that what is it even asking
the solutions of four cos x
equals uh two minus x what is that even
referring to
sean okay so i i want there to be
um a valid solution for these two things
being together
right each graph collides at one point
very nice so it's about this graph
and this graph colliding fine
uh we would usually say intersecting but
that's okay
um where do these graphs intersect right
now you can real quick have a look right
where do the graphs intersect you can
see this
how many spots there's three right now
lucky for you guys
you don't have to find what those three
spots are okay in fact it is finnishly
difficult and beyond the scope of your
course
to find out what they are but they've
asked us something different
they've said explain why
those spots even if you don't know
exactly where they are we can know they
have to be between
negative two and six that's
the goal apparent because after x equals
six
or x equals minus two um the range of
the
two minus x is beyond four ah okay
let's just pause for a minute pens out
of hands for a second because
i want to take parent's idea here and i
want to make sure we're on the same page
so paren correct me if i'm
misrepresenting
what parent just said was after you go
past
x equals negative 2 over that way or x
equals 6
that way so here's like x equals 6. yeah
look at what's happening to this graph
do you see what's happening to it it's
just like dropping
off the rock right and it's just it's
plummeting fine it's going further and
further away
from this guy right do you see that this
guy just happily stays between four and
negative four
just that's it's home but this guy's
just like
i'm out of here right and the same thing
happens over here right negative two off
to the left
it just goes in the opposite direction
so this idea is exactly right i'm going
to show you how to
express that okay so let's do part two
together yeah
so wouldn't it y equals two minus x also
ended
two pi yeah so in fact this graph would
go
up to here and that one up but i've gone
off the board so sorry
okay all right stay with me so here's
how we're going to prove it
uh we're going to consider and this is
literally what i would write
okay
okay we're going to consider this
trigonometry graph okay remember the
whole issue was
it sort of stays within this range and
it never goes outside that it never
strays
so what is serene can you wait
no can you wait thank you just just sit
down
you'll have time
i want you to articulate for me it's
it's on the graph it's probably on your
graph
what is the actual range of this four
cos x function
have a think range means where do you
start and where do you end
it's negative four all the way up to
four right so how we write that we would
say
negative four and four
they're like your boundaries right so
i'm going to use inequality notation
i'm going to do it like this
are you okay with that
so i always think well i always go from
smaller to bigger
you can see that in the direction of the
inequalities right the inequality itself
it's got the small end on one end and
the large end on the other okay you with
me
so we can say this is true from the
graph even from the definition of cosine
thumbs up okay
but what they're asking for is this
straight line to be equal
to that trigonometric graph right so
therefore
to solve that equation that they're
giving us
right the one in the um in the question
is it four cos x first
it is isn't it yeah to solve for cos x
equals two minus x okay
there's a really big leap in thought
here so watch closely
if you want this thing to equal that
then this has to live in that same space
do you agree
right it's like oh when it did it click
for you
okay it's like when are you going to see
mr wu
at the shops well he only ever goes to
the shelves castle towers and soccer or
whichever they happen to be right
if you want to find me if you want to
bump into me at some point intersect
with me there
you're going to have to go to those
shops does that make sense because i'm
lazy i don't drive far away okay
so i need this thing to live in the same
space
as this one you're with me so i'm going
to say therefore
it's got to be between negative four
and four right that's what this 2 minus
x has to do
it has to live in this restricted range
does that make sense
now that's a that's not much to write
but it's a big
mental step you pretty much actually
have done this now because where are we
trying to get to
we're trying to get to negative 2 and 6.
where do you think they come from
negative 2 and 6.
what can we do with this thing any
suggestions
i want to solve for x right now it's
weird to solve this thing for x because
like x is in the middle
another reason why this is such a hard
question but we can still do it we can
still do it
2 minus x i want to get the x by itself
any suggestions what i might do first
i'll subtract 2. now subtracting 2 from
this
means i don't just subtract 2 from that
i have to subtract 2 from
everything right so i'm going to
subtract 2
from all uh did you see it okay good
right
so over here on this side i get negative
six
what do i get in the middle negative x
thank you what do i get on the right
hand side
two you're like wait a second i wasn't
supposed to get negative six i was
supposed to get
pot of six but that's okay because i've
got to deal with this minus sign as well
so what do i do now
think carefully i heard a bunch of
different answers there max what are you
thinking
if i divide by minus one or
minus equivalently that'll do okay so
this will become six
this will become this will become x
this will become negative two that's
good but there's one thing you have to
be super careful for remember we told
you guys
inequalities are like equations in many
ways you can like do the same thing to
everything it's all fine
but they're different in some very
important ways like right now
yeah my inequalities are going to go
different directions so these are less
than or equal to's
they're going to become greater than or
equal to
now that's weird this goes to saran's
point about being confused
about our direction about inequality so
i'm going to write the whole thing
in reverse from smallest to biggest is
that okay
negative 2 x 6.
and if you look closely that's kind of
exactly what they wanted us to prove
negative 2 to 6. are you with me are you
following
so as promised like i told you there
wasn't a whole lot of working in there
but you have to think
tremendously hard that's what these
final questions in the paper are about
okay a little bit yeah